we're speaking now to peter schiff peter
schiff is an economist financial broker
author frequent guest on national news
and hosted the peter schiff show podcast
you may also recognize him from uh that
viral video peter schiff at occupy wall
street i am the one percent let's talk
this currently has over i think it's
four and a half million views on youtube
um peter thanks for joining the show
oh sure thanks for having me in yeah
that video's got like tens of millions
because it's so many different people
have posted it just the version i posted
on my own site a couple of years ago has
five million views but you know it had a
lot of views before i got around to
posting it yeah it's a great video and
if anyone hasn't seen it it's worth
going to check out peter i have to admit
that um
i'm more of a culture and social issues
guy i'm far from an expert on the
economy which is really really an
understatement and i think i'm probably
not alone in that so i'm hoping that
this could be a useful segment if we
just talk about some some kind of basic
issues because i want to learn and the
segment will be useful to me anyway if
nothing else and that's what matters so
i want to get into crypto and bitcoin
and all that but uh let's start with
some of the more sort of traditional
economic issues
very broad strokes right now
putting it simply i have noticed that
things are really expensive right now
and i went i went grocery shopping with
my wife which i rarely do the other day
and i just had one heart attack after
another looking at how expensive
everything was had to be carried out in
a shopping cart so what what is going on
exactly what where is all this coming
from why is everything so expensive what
do you what do you trace it back to
well first of all you ain't seen nothing
yet i mean prices are just starting to
go up so they're going to go a lot
higher and i think even their the
acceleration
is going to is going to pick up so
you're going to see bigger gains
um and and the the question really is
too is you know what's taking so long
you know why were prices
not moving up faster in the last few
years i mean what you know why all of a
sudden because the federal reserve has
been creating a lot of inflation i mean
that's been their monetary policy that's
how they responded to the bursting of
the dot-com bubble and then the housing
bubble and then covid was they just
printed a lot of money but a lot of that
money printing which is really the
inflation right you're creating more
money and so the more money there is the
more expensive everything is because
each unit of money is diminished as the
quantity of money is increased so as you
have more dollars the each dollar is
worth less and now you need more of them
to buy stuff
but a lot of the dollars that the fed
was creating
ended up going into financial assets and
that was the way they were kind of
entering into the economy and the way
the fed was administering this monetary
policy and so you saw big increases in
stock prices or real estate prices all
of those price gains were being fueled
by inflation
but now
you're finally starting to see that
inflation
now showing up
in the consumer goods prices and this is
particularly
a problem in the wake of covid because
what kovid did
was it reduced the supply of goods
because a lot of people who used to work
stopped working and so they were no
longer helping to produce goods and
services that we all buy they weren't
working anymore so the economy not only
in the us but around the world
became less productive and so that we
weren't making as much stuff the proper
response for the fed would have been to
withdraw money from the economy take
money away so that the money supply was
going down with the supply of goods and
services and that would have kind of
kept prices in check but instead the fed
did the opposite the fed decided to
print a bunch of money and mail it out
to the people who were no longer working
and in fact many of the people who got
money from the government got more money
from the government for not working than
they used to earn when they still had
jobs except they were no longer
producing anything so we decreased the
supply of goods and services to buy
while simultaneously increasing the
amount of money in circulation to buy
them and so it's a perfect storm for
prices and the government is going to
throw fuel on the fire you know with
this infrastructure program and all this
other economic stimulus that is really
just inflation because it's all paid for
by the fed uh printing money and you
have to remember
every time the government spends money
it's a tax you know whether they want to
acknowledge it as a tax or not the cost
of government is what it spends not what
it collects in taxes what it spends
so every dollar of federal spending has
to be paid for and the way you pay for
the spending that is financed when the
fed prints money to buy government debt
we pay for that with higher prices so
what you're really experiencing every
time you go and buy something and the
price is much higher than what you
remember that increase is really a tax
that is what all the government spending
is costing you it's costing those higher
prices and since government spending is
going to go way up from here the
inflation tax to pay for it is also
going to go way up
so what you say that it's going to get a
lot worse from here
uh
what is what is our path out of this i
mean how do we
is there a path out how do we how do we
recover from this
well we have to cut government spending
so we can and then the fed won't be
printing as much money to finance all
the debt
but there it doesn't seem to be any
indication that that's going to happen
anytime soon i mean
washington is not going to stop spending
money i mean even the republicans
couldn't cut spending i mean government
spending went way up under trump trump
was a record spender until obama
uh you know trump didn't cut anything uh
and so even the republicans when they
had the house and the senate kept
increasing government spending so why
would government spending stop going up
now when the democrats love spending
money the republicans at least pretend
that they're fiscally conservative and
that they want small government even
though they deliver big government the
democrats promise big government and
they deliver even bigger government than
they promise
and you've got a federal reserve out
there that's willing to monetize all of
it so we're going to keep printing money
we're going to keep borrowing and
spending money and so we're going to
keep paying for all that through
inflation which means the price of
everything we buy is going to go up
how much of the problem you think here
is is you know someone who talks about
these issues
every day um
how much of the problem is that the
the american public
has
become totally desensitized i mean we're
so used to my whole life i'm used to
hearing figures like billion and
trillion tossed around
um
these
massive figures you can't even wrap your
head around it but for one thing because
they're so big you can't wrap your head
around it so it just sort of goes
literally over your head and also we
hear it so often that uh people just
doesn't seem real to people so do you
think
it is is part of the problem that the
american public just doesn't
care that much because they're they're
sort of so used to it by now and
desensitized to it
well i mean the american public is
obviously a big part of the problem
because they're the ones that are voting
for all these politicians that keep on
recklessly spending money
um but yeah i mean they don't understand
the consequences of all this because
they they don't know how to connect the
dots and we haven't had a real crisis
yet where anybody could pinpoint uh the
blame i mean look we got this morning
they announced the trade deficit for
june it was the largest single month
trade deficit in u.s history
you know we keep setting new records for
big trade deficits
these are these are huge problems you
know this is evidence of a
economy that is fundamentally flawed i
mean it is there are major problems all
we're doing is importing you know we're
printing money and spending it on the
stuff that other people make and and so
you know this is going to lead to a
disaster you can't build an economy you
know with these massive twin deficits i
mean trade and budget deficits but the
public is really completely oblivious
and none of the experts are out there
warning about it nobody else even that
you know the people that are supposed to
know that this is a problem don't
recognize it as a problem and you know
20 years ago 30 years ago a lot of
people were worried about the trade
deficit when it was a lot smaller than
it is now just like we had people who
were worried about the budget deficits
when they were a lot smaller but the
problem is the deficits got much bigger
and since we didn't have an immediate
crisis all of a sudden people stopped
worrying and assumed that because we
hadn't had a crisis that we never would
but the problem is now the problems
are so much bigger than they were 10 20
30 years ago when people were worried
about them so that when we do have a
crisis that crisis is also going to be
so much worse because it's a much bigger
bubble that's going to be popping
so i think it's a good a good
opportunity here to
transition over to cryptocurrency which
is one thing i really wanted to talk to
you about because a lot of people would
say that that uh well crypto is the
future that that's our salvation it's
our the solution to a lot of these
problems again i know basically nothing
but looking at it
hearing people talk about crypto and
bitcoin and all this
my immediate sort of gut level reaction
is that bitcoin isn't really a currency
it's more like more like a like a beanie
baby or something like a collectible
that has
a size it's been assigned artificial
value um
am i wrong is this really the future of
currency no
no you're not wrong i mean it is like a
beanie baby except not as valuable as a
beanie baby because you know the beanie
babies are you know actually kind of
cute and you can you know you can put
them in your bedroom and you know you
know decorate and you know i don't know
you could toss them around whatever they
i mean they have some utility obviously
they were way overpriced because you
know a bubble developed in beanie babies
but the reason so many people talk about
bitcoin being the future is because they
bought bitcoin and they hope it's the
future they're betting everything that
it's the future see once you buy bitcoin
all you can do is talk about how great
it is because you have to convince other
people to buy it i mean these are like
the modern day you know harry
kirschner's you know it's like a big uh
pyramid scheme because once you're in it
you have to get more people to buy in
after you to get the price to go up
because that's the only reason the price
will go up if more people come in right
it's like you know bernie madoff it's
you know a ponzi a chain letter pyramid
there's all sorts of ways to kind of
describe it because it's not a pure
ponzi scheme it's not a pure pyramid
scheme but it has elements of each
but
one thing i know for sure is eventually
all these cryptos and you know there's a
lot but there's over 11 000 of them now
right bitcoin is just the most popular
but there's 11 000 of them you know and
the supply grows every day i mean every
day somebody comes up with another one
there's no limit to how many of these
things can be you know conjured into
existence and then of course every
single day the supply of all the
cryptocurrencies goes up because they
create more of the ones that already
exist so the inflation in
cryptocurrencies far exceeds anything
that we're seeing in the actual fiat
currencies that everybody is saying you
got to get rid of
so in many cases you're jumping from the
frying pan into the fire when you get
out of the fiat currencies into the fiat
cryptocurrencies but yeah they're not
even really currencies because they're
not used in the mean of exchange uh
they're not used as a unit of account
you are correct people collect them
that's what they do they're basically
digital tokens and when you're buying
bitcoin you are basically collecting
these tokens
and
right now since more bitcoin collectors
are deciding to you know join the club
and they want to start their collections
and they're they're buying and so right
now the value of the bitcoin collections
is going up because there's more bitcoin
collectors but the only reason that you
collect bitcoin is because you think the
price is going to go up it's not like
you know you know a stamp collection you
know or you know where you can display
the stamps in a nice book and your
friends can come over and you can show
them well look at this stamp or look at
this one or even baseball cards where
you have the cards and you can you know
look at the card and read the stats and
like hey this thing you know you you
have something tangible you know i mean
nobody enjoys showing anybody their
their bitcoin wallet i mean this i mean
unless this is because you're proud of
the fact that it's got a big number on
it but you know there's nothing special
about having bitcoin like it is about
having you know a baseball card that's
100 years old and maybe there's only
three of them and you've got one of the
three you know or whatever it is but
at some point people are going to stop
collecting bitcoins and that's going to
happen when bitcoin prices
fall and they keep falling and then
people no longer are under the belief
that the prices are going to go way up
because that's the reason that a lot of
people don't want to sell their bitcoin
is because they're convinced that they
just hold on to them they'll be rich
but once people no longer have that
expectation
uh and and bitcoin is no longer seen as
this you know
you know a lottery ticket that can't
lose
uh a lot of people are gonna want to
sell and there's gonna be no new people
to buy
and then the price just implodes because
you know there's nothing you can do with
bitcoin bitcoin doesn't actually have
any real utility other than the fact
that people think they're going to get
rich by holding on to it but the minute
you no longer have that expectation then
why would you want bitcoin because you
know you don't do anything with it you
just hold on to it and hope it goes up
well there's a lot more i can ask about
bitcoin unfortunately we're coming up
against a break i i am happy to discover
at least that my my
my priors have been confirmed which is
always nice uh peter schiff great
conversation thanks for joining the show
we appreciate it
my pleasure
you